là pour le peuple chinois
elle marque le centenaire de la création
du parti communiste chinois il marque
également le cinquantenaire du
rétablissement de la république
populaire de chine dans son siège
légitime aux nations unies un événement
historique qui sera sur l'année ont
commémoré en chine
et nous continuerons de travailler
activement pour porter notre coopération
avec l'onu
à un niveau plus élevé
il apporté une contribution toujours
plus grande à la noble cause des nations
unies
monsieur le président
il y a un an
lors des réunions de haut niveau
consacrée au 75e anniversaire des
nations unies les dirigeants de
différents pays du monde ont publié une
déclaration
s'engageant à lutter de façon solidaire
contre lacko bêtise 9 à relever ensemble
les défis à défendre le multilatéralisme
a renforcé le rôle de l'onu et à bâtir
un avenir commun pour les générations
actuelles et à venir
depuis un an le monde subit des
changements et une pandémie jamais connu
depuis un siècle
dans tous les pays du monde les peuples
aspirent plus que jamais à la paix et au
développement
avec une aspiration plus forte à
l'équité à la justice et une
détermination plus ferme à poursuivre la
coopération où chacun y gagne
actuellement la compétition continue de
sévir dans le monde et la société
on a été profondément le changer notre
monde est entré est dans une période de
turbulences et de transformation
nouvelle tout responsable politique doit
répondre aux questions de notre époque
est fait un choix historique avec
confiance courage et le sens de
l'engagement
premièrement
nous devons vaincre la coupe 19 et gagny
ce grand combat crucial pour l'avenir de
l'humanité
et l'histoire de la civilisation humaine
est aussi une histoire de lutte contre
les pandémies c'est toujours en
surmontant les défis que l'humanité a
réalisé un développement et des progrès
plus grand malgré la férocité de la
couvée 19 nous finirons par en triompher
nous devons placer le peuple et la vie
humaine au dessus de tout et protéger la
vie la valeur et la dignité de chacun
nous devons travailler dans le respect
de la science
adopter une attitude scientifique
et y suivre les lois scientifiques
nous devons à la fois bien appliqué les
mesures sanitaires régulière et et
assurer la gestion des urgences et faire
progresser en même temps la lutte
sanitaires et le développement
économique et social il est nécessaire
de renforcer la réponse concertée au
niveau international pour réduire autant
que possible les risques de transmission
transfrontalière les vaccins sont une
arme puissante contre le virus est
soulignée à plusieurs occasions la
nécessité de faire des vaccins un bien
public mondial et d'en assurer
l'accessibilité à un prix abordable pour
les pays en développement
l'urgence c'est d'assurer une
distribution juste et équitable des
vaccins à l'échelle mondiale cette année
la chine s'efforcera de fournir au total
2 milliards de doses au monde
en plus du don de 100 millions de
dollars américains
aux mécaniques ce kovacs la chine fera
don de 100 millions de doses aux autres
pays en développement
annie
est la chine continuera d'apporter son
soutien et de participer au travail
scientifique d'identification des
origines du virus dans le monde et elle
s'oppose fermement à toute forme de
manipulation politique de cette question
deuxièmement
nous devons relancer l'économie et
promouvoir un développement mondial plus
fort plus vert et plus équilibrée
le développement est cruciale pour le
bonheur des peuples face aux graves
impacts de la cofidis nous devons
oeuvrer ensemble pour orienter le
développement mondial avait une nouvelle
phase de croissance
équilibré coordonné pour tous
à cette occasion je voudrais proposer
une initiative pour le développement
mondial
il faut accorder la priorité au
développement nous devons accorder une
place prioritaire développement dans le
cadre macro politique mondiale et
renforcer la coordination des politiques
entre les principales économies du monde
pour assurer la continuité la stabilité
et la viabilité des politiques nous
devons partir des partenariats mondiaux
pour le développement marquée par plus
d'égalité et déquilibre promouvoir la
synergie entre les différents processus
de coopération bilatérale pour le
développement et accélérer la mise en
oeuvre du programme de développement
durable à l'horizon
2030 des nations unies il faut placer
les peuples au coeur de nos
préoccupations nous devons garantir et
améliorer le bien-être des populations
et protéger promouvoir les droits de
l'homme à travers le développement est
vrai un développement pauvre l'est pas
par les peuples et au profit des peuples
de manière à renforcer
son sentiment de bonheur de satisfaction
et de sécurité et a réalisé le plein
épanouissement de l'individu il faut
vrai au bénéfice pour de tous
nos tables ont porté une grande
attention aux besoins particuliers des
pays en développement soutenir les pays
en développement notamment ceux qui sont
fragiles et en grande difficulté par la
suspension de la dette l'aide au
développement et d'autres moyens et
éveiller à régler le problème du
développement déséquilibré insuffisant
dans les différents pays
et entre eux il faut promouvoir le
développement par l'innovation
nous devons saisir les opportunités
historiques offertes par la nouvelle
révolution scientifique et industrielle
pour accélérer la conversion des acquis
scientifiques et technologiques en
force productive réel créer un
environnement
impartiale ouvert équitable non
discriminatoires pour le développement
des sciences des technologies et
explorer de
nouveaux moteurs de croissance
économique pour la préco bêtise n'a pu
réaliser un développement rapide et
vigoureux
il faut veiller à la coexistence
harmonieuse entre l'homme et la nature
nous devons améliorer la gouvernance
environnementale mondiale lutter
activement contre le changement
climatique et construire un avenir pour
l'homme et la nature il faut accélérer
la transition verte et réalise une
reprise et un développement vers
la chine s'efforcera d'atteindre le pic
des émissions de co2 avant 2030 et
s'efforcera de réaliser la neutralité
carbone avant 2060
ces objectifs nécessite des efforts
intenses et la chine il consacrera
toutes ses forces la chine soutiendra
rigoureusement le développement des
énergies vertes et
les basses émissions de carbone dans les
pays en développement
elle ne construira plus de nouveaux
projets de centrales à charbon à
l'étranger
il faut adopter des actions
pragmatiques nous devons accroître les
investissements dans le développement
promouvoir en priorité la coopération
sur la réduction de la pauvreté la
sécurité alimentaire elle la riposte
sanitaires et les vaccins le financement
du développement le changement
climatique le développement vers
l'industrialisation
l'économie numérique l'inter connexion
il faut accélérer la mise en oeuvre du
programme développement durable à
l'horizon 2030 et construire
un monde
avec un développement mondial commun
la chine a annoncé l'octroi dans les
trois ans à venir et dette
supplémentaire de 3 milliards de dollars
américains pour épauler les et pays en
développement dans la lutte contre la
copie 19 et la reprise des
développements économiques et sociales
troisièmement
nous devons renforcer la solidarité et
mettre en pratique le concept des
relations internationales marquée par le
respect mutuel et une coopération chacun
gagne un monde de paix de développement
c'est un monde où coexistent des
civilisations aux formes variées et des
foires différentes
de cheminement vers la modernisation
la démocratie n'est pas la priorité
exclusive d'un pays quelconque mais un
droit de tous les peuples l'évolution
récente de la situation internationale
prouve une fois de plus que
l'intervention militaire extérieure et
la prétendue transformation démocratique
ne conduisent qu'à des conséquences
désastreuses nous devons travailler
énergiquement pour faire rayonner les
valeurs communes de l'humanité que sont
la paix le développement des kits et la
justice la démocratie et la liberté et
rejeter les mentalités de blocs
et du jeu à somme nulle
les différences et les problèmes
difficiles à éviter doivent être traités
par voie de dialogue et de coopération
sur la l'égalité du respect mutuel entre
les pays
le succès d'un pays ne signifie pas
forcément l'échec d'un autre
et notre monde est suffisamment grand
pour permettre à tous les pays de se
développer et de prospérer
nous devons préconisé le dialogue et
l'inclusion de tous et rejeté la
confrontation exclusion nous devons
construire un nouveau type de relations
internationales
fondées sur le respect mutuel l'équité
la justice et la coopération chacun
gagne élargir les convergences
d'intérêts et trouver des terrains
d'entente
autant que possible la nation chinoise
transmet poursuit les concepts de paix
de bonne entente et d'harmonie jamais la
chine n'a envahi
ou opprimés les autres nations nous n'a
prétendu à l'hégémonie et elle ne le
fera jamais elle est toujours elle est
depuis toujours un bâtisseur de la paix
mondiale qui contribuent au
développement dans le monde en défendant
l'ordre international et en fournissant
des biens publics la chine continuera
d'offrir de nouvelles opportunités au
monde par son développement
quatrièmement
nous devons améliorer la gouvernance
mondiale et pratiquer un véritable
multilatéralisme
il n'y a qu'un seul système
international dans le monde celui centré
sur les nations unies
il n'y a qu'un seul ordre international
à savoir l'ordre fondé sur le droit
international et il n'y a qu'elle nous
sommes de règles les règles
fondamentales régissant les relations
internationales
fondées sur les buts et principes de la
charte des nations unies
l'onu doit porter haut l'étendard du
véritable de multilatéralisme et servir
d'instance essentiel où tous les pays
travaillent ensemble à préserver la
sécurité universel à partager les fruits
du développement et orienter l'avenir du
monde l'onu et est invité à assurer un
ordre international stable à augmenter
la représentation et le droit à la
parole des nombreux pays en
développement dans les affaires
internationales et a joué un rôle chef
de file dans la promotion de la
démocratie et de l'état de droit dans
les relations internationales elle doit
faire avancer de manière équilibrée le
travail dans les trois champs majeurs
que sont la sécurité le développement et
les droits de l'homme élaborer un agenda
commun se concentrer sur les questions
et aiguille redoublé d'action pour faire
rénover effectivement les engagements
pris par les différentes parties au
sujet du multilatéralisme monsieur le
président le monde se trouve une fois de
plus à la croisée des chemins
de l'histoire je suis convaincu que le
courant de la paix du développement et
du progrès de l'humanité est
irrésistible
travaillons main dans la main dans une
confiance sera fermée pour affronter les
menaces et les défis planétaires et
construire nous
un avenir commun pour l'ensemble de
l'humanité un monde meilleur
pour nous tous
[Applaudissements]
en 10 ans venus au nom de l'assemblée
générale je remercie
doré le président de la république
démocratique populaire de chine de cette
déclaration nous avons entendu le
dernier orateur du débat général pour la
réunion de ce matin la
quatrième le séance plénière se tiendra
immédiatement après la levée de la
présente réunion la séance est levée
pour
et la quatrième séance plénière de
l'assemblée générale est ouverte
excellence